what they find now is that social
isolation and loneliness are as toxic to
our health as smoking half a pack of
cigarettes a day or being obese so this
is huge the health effects are very real
tell me about the origins of this study
that you're currently in charge of
the study started in
1938. it's the longest study that we
know of of the same people going through
their entire lives
uh and it started as two studies that
didn't even know about each other one
was started at Harvard College
undergraduate students a 19 year old who
were chosen by their professors as fine
upstanding specimens and it was to be a
study of adolescence moving into young
adulthood
so of course if you want to study normal
young adult development you study all
white males from Harvard right it's like
so Politically Incorrect and then the
other study uh was a study of juvenile
delinquency it was started at Harvard
Law School by a professor named Sheldon
Gluck and his wife Eleanor Gluck they
were interested in why some children
from really disadvantaged backgrounds
and troubled homes managed to stay on
good developmental paths and stayed out
of trouble and so both of those studies
were then put together in the 1970s as
contrasting groups one very privileged
one very underprivileged and we've
followed them their spouses and now
their children for 85 years
it was all men to start with was all men
now more than half women why because
that's kids plus spouses that have been
introduced yeah and this is only in
America
only in America right I mean some now
live abroad but they all started in
America
do you see any issues about this being
weird uh Western educated industrialized
etc etc
it is totally weird it is totally that
and so what we've done and and this is
particularly in the book that we're just
publishing
um we've made sure only to present
findings that have been corroborated by
other studies around the world studies
of groups that are not weird Western
educated white right no we haven't so so
people of color people of very different
ethnic groups and cultural backgrounds
so that we're not presenting findings
that we believe are pretty specific to
this very narrow demographic yeah
right you want everybody you want it to
be as applicable as possible yeah okay
so what are the sort of things that
you're asking people
oh boy well we're we're studying the big
domains of human life okay mental health
physical health work
including uh promotions getting fired
successes failures
um relationships not just Intimate
Relationships but all kinds of
relationships so we're studying all of
that and we're studying we've studied
the same things for 85 years but then
we've used different methods so you know
to be sure we ask them how happy are we
are you we ask them many many different
sorts of questions but we also ask other
people about them like spouses and
children and friends we also then use
other measures we videotape them talking
to their spouses about their biggest
concerns we bring them into our
laboratory and deliberately stress them
out and then watch how quickly they
recover from stress
we put them into MRI scanners we scan
their brains and we watch how their
brains light up when we show them
different kinds of pictures to see how
the brain is interconnected and wired
when it's looking at happy pictures and
sad pictures for example so these are
all different ways of trying to get
Windows on well-being because that's
what we're studying we're studying human
thriving human well-being you did DNA
testing blood samples EEG EKG all manner
of different health markets so this
isn't just self-rated happiness how much
no not at all and in fact that what I
love about this is it's kind of a
history of science because you know like
we're drawing blood for DNA and and mRNA
right and those things weren't even
imagined in 1938 when the study began so
what we love is seeing ourselves bring
new methods online to study the same
things wasn't there some really stupid
questions that you asked people like
whether someone's ticklish or not
exactly we still don't know why they
asked are you ticklish but they did they
must have thought that in well we didn't
keep it in we don't re we don't repeat
the questions that we don't see a reason
to continue right okay so it's gone now
no one knows if you're if they're
ticklish what if what if all of the most
well we could know if they're ticklish
what if all of the most interesting
insights were coming out of ticklishness
correlation well you know that's
actually been one of the cool things
about the digital age we scanned all of
these paper documents you know hundreds
of thousands of pieces of paper scan
them into searchable PDFs and now we can
search them we didn't even know that we
asked them if they were ticklish until
we had these searchable PDFs and then we
started you know putting in you could
put in the term mother and it will pull
up every mention of the word mother in
in a man's file over his entire life or
a woman's file now so so what we have is
the ability to find things that we did
not know existed in our database
who is the person or team that is in
charge of pulling this data out because
it must be an incredibly sophisticated
data science group of people that's
managing all of this well my co-author
Mark Schultz is really the best most
sophisticated data science person I know
thank goodness I mean he is he is my
partner in in all of this and Mark
Schultz now heads the data science
program at Bryn Mawr College it's a new
program and
what we need is people who are
sophisticated in managing uh
multi-generational data and also what's
cool is you know when you study siblings
like we've studied all the children and
that includes siblings and the same
families but you can't treat them as
separate beings out in the world you
have to know that siblings are more
connected than
to others the data needs to be able to
map the interrelations between people
too exactly so we use something called
multi-level modeling which is a very
sophisticated theoretical
statistical modeling technique and thank
goodness I have people who know how to
do that because I don't do it I think
that's really cool it I also read about
how there's a particular uniqueness
between longitudinal versus a
cross-sectional study the fact that most
studies at the moment are this sort of
snapshot in time asking people to relive
memories and to sort of give you self
ratings based on things that happened in
the past what's the advantage that you
guys have got by doing it the way that
you have
longitudinal studies get to follow
people over their entire lives and come
back and ask them the same things and
take the same measurements over time the
problem with snapshots is that it can
generate
false correlations so if we take a
snapshot of peop a group in their 20s a
group today in their 40s a group today
in their 60s we can believe that we see
the progression of life from age 20 to
60 but that can lead us into trouble the
best the best illustration of this comes
from a joke that is kind of particular
to the US but maybe your International
audience will get it Claude pepper was a
senator from the state of Florida and he
once quipped that when he looked at
South Florida which is filled with many
younger Cuban Americans and many older
Jewish Americans who have retired there
he said when I look at South Florida I
would have to believe that you are born
Cuban and you die Jewish right because
if we just take snapshots we can imagine
that that's how life progresses that you
start out as a little Cuban child and
you become an old Jewish person
okay so that's that's the problem we're
dealing with and that's why longitudinal
studies offer a really unique and
important perspective on how life
progresses
you have this huge data set you have how
many people have been included in the
entire study now all together over two
thousand okay you have over 2 000 people
Millions probably have bit bits of data
oh yeah you have decided to focus this
book on happiness why you could have
done it on uh approaches to culture you
could have had it on voting history you
could have had it on on anything right
yeah we could have why choose happiness
well we chose happiness from a
particular angle and the angle is the
role that relationships play human
connections play in our lives both in
our happiness and in our physical health
because
what surprised us was was certainly that
relationships make us happier actually
that wasn't such a surprise that stands
to reason but we began to find that the
people who stayed healthy longer and who
lived longer
we're the ones who were better connected
and were more satisfied with their
relationships and this began to emerge
in the 1980s we didn't even believe it
at first until other studies began to
find the same thing because the question
was how could the quality of my
relationships get into my body how could
it predict whether I'm likely to get
coronary artery disease or arthritis how
could that possibly be a fact and so we
thought that this was powerful enough
and the effect of good relationships was
powerful enough that we wanted to bring
this to the world because it really
matters for well-being so the single
biggest influence on happiness is
relationships well two big influences
one is taking care of your health so
that turns out to be hugely important
it's not a surprise
um but it you know not smoking regular
exercise eating well not abusing alcohol
or drugs all of that matters
tremendously
but we we felt that what was neglected
in the public discussion of well-being
was the power of relationships which
turn out to be so powerful let me give
you an example that what they find now
is that social isolation and loneliness
are as toxic to our health as smoking
half a pack of cigarettes a day or being
obese
so this is huge the the health effects
are very real
was there anything else that competed
with health or relationships when it
came to determining happiness
in terms of their the size of the effect
no not that I'm aware of could we set up
some analyzes that might show us
something new perhaps but those were
just the big elephants in the room if
you will and you know health is
but maybe not when you started this
study so much of a priority but the
communication around the wellness
industry around food diet you know
smoking just looking at how difficult it
is to get a packet of cigarettes and how
much less sexy they are than they would
have been when this study began you know
yes absolutely not not a massive smoking
fan okay so let's invert it
what are the biggest misconceptions that
people have in your opinion when it
comes to what constitutes a happy life
yes
I'm so glad you asked that because
there's so many big misconceptions
probably the biggest is that
if you do all the right stuff you can be
happy all the time
because one of the things that's very
clear from following these thousands of
people
is that nobody's happy all the time that
a happy life does not mean being happy
24 7. and in some ways that's obvious
but we can sell each other the myth that
if we just do all the right stuff we'll
be happy no matter what that you know if
you think about social media now we
curate our lives for each other in such
a way that you could look at somebody
else's Instagram feed of you know being
on beautiful beaches or beautiful meals
or happy times with friends and you
could imagine oh that person has it all
figured out that person's having the
good life
because I don't you know I don't post my
photos of myself getting up in the
morning hungover or really confused
about my life I don't do that right the
problem with this curation that we all
do for each other is that can lead us to
feel like we are the only one who for
whom life isn't beautiful all the time
and so I just want to name that that is
a myth that we accidentally sell each
other and the media sells it to us right
because they want us to buy things and
they say you know if you buy this car
you'll be happier you know if you use
this face cream you'll look young
forever
um and so we are constantly being given
these messages that there is a way to
have the non-stop happy life so I just
want to name that
the the other thing that's worth saying
I think is that you do not need to be an
extrovert to get these benefits you can
be quite shy that that's not a problem
that what we know is that we all differ
in the extent to which we need people
and benefit from people
that what we what we do believe from our
research is that everybody needs like
somebody who they feel has their back
right and that you need one connection
that's really solid to feel like the
world is an okay place for you
but that you can be a shy person who
finds a lot of people exhausting and
that that's perfectly fine not to have a
large circle of friends or connections
and so I want to name that because
sometimes in talking about this subject
people can hear it and say well if I'm
shy I'm out of luck and and that's not
true
it suggests that
introverts in one regard actually might
have a little bit of an easier time here
because they need to find fewer people
in order to get themselves to the level
of social satisfaction that they need
well that's an interesting idea I
haven't thought of it that way
um
if you need to have four different
groups you've got your dance class and
your comedy class and your movie night
and you games night and all the rest of
it that's actually that's harder in one
regards because you need to be able to
recruit all of these people but I
suppose you are predisposed to be the
kind of person that would go out and not
find that effortful so the point is
balancing your predisposition for
sociality with the people that are in
your life and yes and I think what you
said is the key that that if you are an
extrovert you find other people
energizing which means that it's
motivating to go out and find people to
be with if you're an introvert you find
a lot of other people draining
exhausting right so so you're not
motivated to go to go seek out the
parties that is my favorite definition
of introversion and extroversion it's
the most useful one do you find yourself
being energized by being around people
or do you find yourself being energized
by being on your own it's way more
useful than the other definitions of
introversion than extroversion yeah and
less pathologizing you know we sort of
glorify extroversion at least in the in
the American culture and and uh
introversion is a perfectly wonderful
way to go through life it's just a
different way of being
how much of our happiness is genetically
predetermined
somebody has actually tried to work this
out there's a psychologist named Sonya
lubemiersky and she has calculated
that about half about 50 percent of our
well-being is genetically determined and
about 10 she estimates is based on our
current life situation and then another
40 percent is more under our control
it's malleable we can move the needle
about 40 percent in our level of
happiness
what does happiness mean so we're going
to use that word a lot during this
conversation
in this context what are you optimizing
for what what is the happiness concept
that we're looking at
again there's research on this and it
seems that happiness falls into two big
buckets one is hedonic well-being it
comes from Hedonism right it's like am I
having fun right now okay so like I'm
having a good time having this
conversation with you so my hedonic
well-being is is high right
um in a few minutes something really
annoying may happen in my hedonic
well-being might plummet then there's
this other flavor of well-being called
you demonic well-being the term comes
from I think Aristotle eudemonia and it
it means the quality of life that is
Meaningful
satisfying right the best example was uh
given to me by a mother of young
children so she said you know I'm
reading to my daughter before she goes
to bed I'm trying to get her to go to
sleep and I've read her the book
Goodnight Moon seven times and she says
mommy read it to me one more time one
more time and and I'm exhausted right
I've had or I'm I'm just so exhausted
I'm falling asleep reading this book
am I having fun reading Goodnight Moon
for the eighth time no way is this the
most meaningful thing I could be doing
right now with my life absolutely and
that's the difference between hedonic
and eudemonic well-being I've got a
theory about that
um how do you say diversion or that that
separation between those two so let me
throw some bro signs back at you yeah I
first learned about that difference
between let's call it um like pleasure
and meaning or happiness and meaning
perhaps Daniel Kahneman and Daniel
Gilbert two big psychologists from the
last 50 years uh Daniel Kahneman
mentioned he thinks a good life is one
which in retrospect you are glad that
you lived so that's one which is
Meaningful which moment to moment may
not maximize pleasure but in retrospect
is one that gives you meaning Daniel
Gilbert on the other hand said he was
much more and in the moment uh Hedonism
kind of guy not sort of strippers and
cocaine but a a lounge chair and a nice
cocktail perhaps
I've got it in my head that the waiting
that people should prioritize in their
lives about whether or not they're
optimizing more for Hedonism or more for
eudaimonia
heavily should be influenced by their
disposition in the same way of the
introversion and extroversion thing that
we were talking about so you can imagine
for me
I'm a an introspective guy I ruminate I
I like to consider myself as part of a
grander plan I reflect on things that
have gone I plan for things that are
about to come for me if I optimize for
Hedonism I will spend a good bit of time
reflecting on something which doesn't
give me a massive amount of meaning in
the moment whereas if I am the sort of
person that makes sacrifices in the now
that makes me feel good in the future
that achieves things that I feel have
got a greater contribution to them
overall that is the sort of thing that's
going to make me feel good longer term
so I actually think that there is some
sort of a spectrum that we've got going
on here where people can optimize for a
more hedonistic or a more demonic life
yes and your um propensity to reflect to
ruminate to introspect is is very
important at deciding how you should do
this and I have friends who are
perfectly fine just in chewing through
kind of a very similar routine they've
got the things that bring them pleasure
they've got their golf they've got their
holidays they've got their dog walks
they've got the whatever and they don't
need to go through uh perhaps as
elaborate of a construction of life in
order to try and generate this meaning
because they just don't ruminate quite
so much they're not they haven't got
that same introspection whereas I have
friends who are even more tuned up on
the introspection side than I am and
they can't bear to give themselves a day
off they can't bear to have so I I think
that very much people are optimizing for
the kind of life that they are
predisposed to find Value in I think
that's absolutely right and in fact you
and I are more similar in that regard
you know in that I'm I kind of am in
very introspective too and I uh and and
sometimes I envy my friends who can just
go through their you know their lives of
Golf and Tennis and Bridge games and
yeah like why can't I just do that
um there's another flavor of happiness
that some researchers at Columbia
University have begun to find and again
what they do is they measure people
um and on these three Dimensions there's
a third
and they call it the psychologically
rich life so rather than prioritizing
the pleasure I get right now from my
golf game or the feeling that I am doing
something meaningful by talking on this
podcast with you right the eudaimonia
it's the psychologically rich life it's
new Rich experiences so it might be
travel to new places there are some
people who just want to spend their
whole lives traveling to places they've
never been before not because they build
anything not even because it's fun in
the moment all the time but because this
novelty and the psychological richness
is what they crave and I think that one
way of thinking about this is that we're
all we all have these Desires in us but
that they are higher or lower depending
on how we're built psychologically uh
probably even neurologically and
physically you know that some people
prioritize one over the others why would
you write on this curiosity scale
I think I rate high on the
psychologically Rich scale that I find
that I get bored that I'm I'm a good
starter of things but I'm not so great
at maintaining so that's why like I you
know it turned out that like I was on
track to run like organiz like
Psychiatry departments like in my field
you know I'm a psychiatrist like you you
would run a Psychiatry Department in a
hospital and I was on that track and I
realized oh my God I would just hate
this you know that I sat around these
meetings with all these people in suits
um and and that they were talking about
problems that I know were really
important but I just didn't care like
insurance regulations and things like
that and so I realized that that I'm
just not gonna be one of those people
that for me I need
some stimulation and so actually that's
why I like doing this with you
is that is very enlivening for me it's
not just that I'm having a good time
it's that it's stimulating because
you have different takes than I've heard
before on some of these matters you ask
me questions that I haven't thought of
before that is um that's enlivening for
me I think that the perfect uh way if
you if you weren't to have any sort of
routine life is going to be so chaotic
that you basically can't do anything
right there has to be some sort of
routine I have some friends that a total
nomadic Wanderers and and they wake up
in a different time zone in a different
city in a different whatever fair play I
think that's a very small cohort of
people I think most people want some
sort of routine with some amount of
variety within it and you know from my
side again I think whatever that uh
curiosity scale is pick a few hundredth
percentile and that's where I would be
now what I have is the opportunity to do
something which is still routinized but
within that I get to cycle through the
novelty as well right this is not a
conversation I've had before this is not
a person that I've spoken to before this
is a topic that I've got some idea about
but not all of it and it's new and it's
different and the backdrop and all the
rest of it so I think um just trying to
think about an applied or continuing to
dig into applied Solutions here
certainly for people that have that high
degree of novelty seeking that they want
they want to have adventure and do new
things but are restricted by any one of
the million things that life can stop
you from doing whether it be
responsibilities Financial restrictions
just time whatever bravery even there
are ways that you can cycle through that
give yourself that psychological what
was it psychological richness
psychological richness whilst not
throwing everything out of the window
selling your possessions and going to
Vietnam right right okay yeah give me
you said in the book that a good life is
by its very nature a complicated life
why is that the case why is a good knife
not just a simple life
because life is complicated by
definition I mean think about the
pandemic none of us expected that you
know and then suddenly life was way more
complex in a moment right in a week
everything changed so much changed in
our lives right for most of us some more
than others and and I think that what we
know is that life is constantly bringing
us things we don't expect there's a it's
a proverb that I'm sure you've heard uh
people plan and God laughs you know this
idea that we can you know we can predict
what's going to happen it can be simple
it can be controllable and that's just
not the truth of human existence and so
I think that's why we say you know the
good life is a complicated life because
a bad life is a complicated life too
it's just that every life is complicated
okay relationships you said Health
massive impact on happiness
relationships next biggest happy
happiness impact
why what why do relationships matter
well we believe that relationships are
stress Regulators
um that in fact
we're all meant to respond to stress
right we're all meant to go into fight
or flight mode when we're having a
challenge you know and you can feel it
if something scary happens or
challenging your heart rate goes up the
blood goes to your muscles because
you're ready to to move into action
that's what the body is designed to do
but the body is also meant to go back to
equilibrium to Baseline when the threat
is removed
um so if if I have something happen
that's really upsetting during my day
and I start ruminating about it I can
feel my heart rate increase I can feel
myself really start to rev up right
if I go home and I can talk to my
partner or you know I can call somebody
on the phone who's a good listener I can
literally feel my body calm down again
and what we think happens is that people
who can't do that stay in a kind of
chronic fight or flight mode because
stressors come along every day and that
we can if we don't have those emotion
Regulators that relationships can be for
us that we stay in this mode where the
body has higher levels of circulating
stress hormones the body has higher
levels of chronic inflammation and that
those things break down body systems so
that question of well how could it be
that that stress bad relationships
loneliness makes you more likely to get
coronary artery disease and arthritis
how could it be both well it seems that
there are these general effects
of the chronic stress mode that break
down multiple body systems and that's
what so that's what we're saying that
good relationships protect us from
and there's pretty good data so far to
support this hypothesis
that is
mitigating the impact of stress
by giving yourself a sense of support
from the people that are around you
somebody to talk to what about the other
side of that
um did you look at how relationships
play a role in allowing you to further
sort of Revel and enjoy good things that
happen in life are they able to extend
out the enjoyment as opposed to just
restrict down the negative absolutely
absolutely you know they've done studies
of laughter I mean and that people who
laugh more are healthier that there is
something about releasing these hormones
that enhance physical well-being I can't
get into the Neuroscience of that that's
above my pay grade but
um but what we know is that when people
are relaxed this is why meditation works
as well so it's not just in
relationships but laughter warm
connections you know another person's
touch
uh not just doesn't not only calms us
down but enhances our well-being our
sense of connectedness and we believe
that that then has these positive
protective effects you know that there
is a maximum speed that you can stroke
somebody's arm at in order to release
the amount of oxytocin I did not know
that okay so we have around our body
still got the upper bound that is set by
when we were furry apes or
the speed at which you would be able to
pick and groom the people around you
that is still the upper bound I want to
say that it is about
it's between three and twenty
centimeters per second I can't remember
I'll I'll find the book that I was
talking to uh Roy about but um once you
get above that it's it it would be you
would be moving so quickly that you
wouldn't be able to effectively pick
anything out so the oxytocin release
that you get from paired grooming
occurs within this particular window for
stroking I love this I love this and I
bet if you do it more rapidly it's just
annoying 100
um it's also you see this in uh studies
of Toddlers and and babies as well that
are crying you can test by moving your
hand up and down them and it's this
particular speed whatever it is
centimeters per second that's the one
that calms crying the quickest
wow wow so clever um Okay so obviously
people who have good relationships are
likely to be like other people who have
good relationships which means that
you're going to select for a cohort of
people that may have other things in
common as well how are you able to
separate out the people that have good
relationships from the other people who
also were in a good financial situation
or they had this particular start in
Life or lived in this particular area or
economic influences all of the other
life stuff
well that's a methodology question an
important one like how do you how do you
know that an effect isn't being driven
by something else like your income or
where you were born and so what we try
to do is statistically level the playing
field control for in the jargon uh
control for these other things so we
make sure that we level the playing
field that we we uh
but that your socioeconomic status where
you were born privileged underprivileged
uh ethnicity all of that gets taken into
account when we do these analyzes and
then if we still see an effect then we
know we've got something if the effect
goes away then we say oh well okay so
maybe this is more about social class
and it's not about what we think it is
and this is this is how we so the
analyzes statistical analysis is is a
really complicated Endeavor what about
marriage what role does marriage play in
happiness
it plays a big role I married people
happier they are actually they are and
they live longer now
are some married people unhappy
absolutely we know that right you know
so so it's all over the map but if you
just take thousands of people and you do
great big averages
uh married people are on average uh
somewhat happier but that also that
doesn't include that doesn't mean that
you have to have a marriage license it
just means that people in an intimate
partnership
art as a group happier can you be happy
without an intimate partnership
absolutely but you have to beat the odds
not that great the odds aren't it's not
like these effects are that massive I
was going to say what's the size of the
effect that we're talking about with
marriage you know I can't I would be
making it up if I quoted you in effect
size but you're you're asking exactly
the right question because it is what's
the effects enough for you tonight it's
going to be statistically significant
right it is it's right it's not nothing
but it could be
statistically significant particularly
if you're studying thousands of people
and and quite small effects so you're
asking the right question I just don't
have the answer at my fingertips what
about the introduction of children
foreign
it neither makes us happier nor less
happy at least from the studies that
have been done right it's a life path
it's a life choice right and so the
people who choose to have children
um
are neither happier nor less happy than
the people who choose not to have
children now that said you know I had
two kids and I can't imagine my life
without them was life hard because I had
kids yes was it wonderful yes it was all
of that so I think there you know what
we know I think from the research is
that these Life Choices do not do not
prescribe whether you're going to be
happy or not they are Simply Life
Choices
hmm
there has to be things that engender a
better type of life and things that
don't though so for instance like the
life choice to not have any friends
would be a life choice but it would
impact our happiness but it would impact
happiness
um the life choice to if you if you call
it a choice to abuse alcohol to abuse
drugs uh is a bad choice
um the life choice to engage in things
that harm other people turn out to and
genderless happiness the Life Choices
dig into that what do you mean well
things that harm other people give you
less happiness uh it usually what goes
around comes around
um there's there's a did they show up in
the data at all yeah yeah that the
people who were really self-centered and
the people who did not take care of
others were less happy
wow and that leads into presumably as
does that control for the number of
social connections that they have uh
did we do that precise analysis I am not
sure
it's the absolute Pinnacle or the the
center point of this The Hub at the
middle of all of these spokes is social
relationships and then you have a person
the one that's likely to be
self-centered that's maybe no committing
more crime or petty theft from from
close friends or relatives is likely to
have fewer friends is it because they're
self-centered or is it because they've
got fewer friends
that's an interesting question well we
do think that these kind of anti-social
behaviors are drivers of not just fewer
friends but of less happiness that it
doesn't work well
um
you know I I'm not going to get into
this because we don't want to get
political but I would believe that some
of the most egregiously self-centered
people in our political worlds actually
have the most troubled inner lives from
all the clues I can get and again I'm
observing from the outside but I am a
psychiatrist and it does seem that the
people who are much more self-centered
are more troubled more tormented well
they're not going to be at peace you
don't get anybody like that and think
peace yeah right now you don't did you
look at the sort of characteristics in
an intimate relationship
that you should look to optimize for in
a partner
the the things that predicted happiness
in that relationship the best or in
terms of Life yeah yeah
two things a lot one was maintaining
curiosity
about the other person and adapting to
change
and I'll say something about each so
maintaining curiosity
there there was a study of how well how
good people were at guessing what the
other one was feeling
and it turns out that we are best at
knowing what our partner is feeling
when we first get together
because if you think about it when
you're dating someone you're really
trying is this person into me and how do
I tell and so you really attuned to them
you're attuned to every little signal
right
what they find is that when people have
been together a long time they're much
less tuned into each other they are much
less good at knowing what the other's
feeling pardon me
um
that it turns out that we stop paying
attention that we think we know each oh
I know what she's gonna say I know you
know I I know this I got this so it
turns out that staying attuned is really
helpful maintaining curiosity even about
this person you think you know so well
so one of my meditation teachers taught
me this and and he taught it to me about
meditation but it works in relationships
too to ask yourself the question what's
here now that I haven't noticed before
so you know I'm having dinner with this
person and I've had dinner with her for
years what's here now that I haven't
noticed before about this person like
that can be a really useful interesting
exercise okay so that's the Curiosity
part maintaining curiosity just to hold
just to dig in there why do you think it
is that maintaining curiosity impacts
happiness
because we all want to be seen right we
really do we want to be known for Who We
Are
so what we do what we hate is being
stereotyped being typed so you want to
optimize for a partner that is the type
of person who will stay curious that
will stay curious notice if you change
your shoes that will ask you about your
day at work that will care about your
whatever yeah yeah the worst thing you
can say to your partner is you always or
you never that's like a real problem in
a relationship and the reason why it's a
problem is that it's a stereotype nobody
always anything or does never does
something you know it's it's I wonder
whether uh I'm gonna forget about it
again what was it psychological richness
richness thank God psychological
richness has to correlate your desire
for psychological richness 100 has to
correlate with your level of curiosity
when it comes to your partner must I
think so I think that would be the
driving for one of the driving forces
behind it so that would be interesting
to see the psychological richness mapped
over the top of that that would be super
interesting are people who prioritize
psychological richness uh more likely to
choose Partners who also prioritize that
are they more likely to have happier
relationships because they're the
Curious ones yep yep um
speak to Mark ask Mark tell Mark to to
do that to do that all right so we've
got uh curiosity caring about the other
person what they're doing what was the
other the other thing another one is
adaptability to change so if you think
about it
each of us is always a work in progress
we're always changing as human beings
you get together with somebody and you
say oh I really like this person I want
to be with this person but this person
is evolving right before your eyes and
you're evolving right before your eyes
and so what happens is that the in the
most stable relationships you have two
people who are constantly evolving
if we can adapt to that accept it and
even support it then those relationships
are more satisfying they're more stable
if we want to fix the person we're with
in a certain mold and never let them out
of that mold
that's stultifying for both people and
so this idea of adaptability it's almost
like learning new dance steps as you go
as a couple that those are the
relationships that seem to do the best
um the other data science book that I
got really interested in over the last
year was don't trust your gut by Seth
Stevens davidowitz so interesting guy
xdate the scientist at Google and he
looked at the
strongest predictors for long-term
relationship success now this wasn't
necessarily happiness this was do they
stay together the longest yeah and all
of the things that people optimize for
on dating apps and when speaking to each
other and asking questions and none of
the things that predict so um height had
no bearing on it income had no bearing
on it education level had no bearing on
it the things that did that came up that
are interesting to kind of tally in with
what you're talking about psychological
stability so how long after an incident
do you get back to Baseline
um growth mindset
uh conscientiousness
and there was one other thing that I
can't remember but just thinking about
that happiness in a relationship and
longevity in a relationship will
probably be correlated but they're not
exactly the same thing they're going to
be slightly different right
um You can imagine somebody that is very
stubborn in a relationship miserable but
will stay together that could be a an
archetypal person that you could find
yeah yeah
but certainly that
um conscientiousness I.E attentive
um focused uh discipline pain like
giving giving my all to the partner the
psychological stability would allow you
to be adaptable to deal with things and
to not uh be too
um swayed by them and the growth mindset
is precisely what you're talking about
so it's interesting to see those two
studies kind of marry over the top it is
I'm gonna take a look at that because if
that makes the things you listed make
total sense to me given what I know
about human development
can friendships replace a marriage yes
they can they don't and you never have
to be married to to get these benefits
the friendships can totally uh be in
that place be the the people who have
your back the people who support you and
the support we get from relationships
first of all we can't get it all from a
marriage anyway you can't get everything
from an intimate partnership that's
another myth that's worth calling out
um but think about exclusively reliant
on just you and your significant other
isn't enough no and we can imagine that
well if my relationship doesn't provide
me with everything I need then there
must be something wrong with the
relationship not true think of all the
things that we need from relationships I
mean certainly we need intimacy and we
need sex but we also you know we need
fun which you can also you can get in
many different relationships we need
moral support
um my neighbor who always has the right
tool when I need to fix something in my
house and I never have the right tool
you know he'll he'll support me by
bringing over his toolbox and you know
the people who uh you play tennis with
or the people who drive you to the
doctor there's so many
ways that we support each other and so
the idea is that we ought to have people
in our Lives who provide us with
different things and certainly
friendships can can provide all of what
we need there does not have to be an
intimate partnership in the picture did
you not say though that the intimate
partnership is the most important
relationship to have presumably that
means that it can't be replaced by even
a million friends wouldn't be able to
replace everything of that
you know In fairness nobody's done that
comparison I think it would be an
impossible one to do in a rigorous way
so I guess the bottom line is I don't
know
uh but I know people who have never had
an intimate partnership
and have very satisfying Rich lives
that would be presumably an outlier most
people
end up in some sort of a partnership or
at least sequential Partnerships
throughout their life most people do but
there is a there's a growing cohort of
people a growing percentage of people
who don't do that still you're right the
majority of people do have some intimate
partnership as they go through life
what is the optimal number of friends
there isn't an optimal number for just
the reasons we talked about right right
there's no optimal number that for you
know for me it might be one person for
you it might be 50 people uh I know
there have been all these calculations
about we can't really have more than 150
relationships in Our Lives who knows it
varies so much depending on our
temperaments our proclivities uh so no
optimal number okay what about the
relationship between relationships and
uh health and body you mentioned that
earlier on but there was some stuff to
do with it being neuroprotective later
in life links to all sorts of things
yeah what uh someone's a little
skeptical about the relationship to
between relationships and their health
what some of these stats that you can
Hammer that home with
foreign well in terms of living longer I
mean we know for example that married
people live longer than single people
like by several years uh Men actually
get an even bigger benefit than women
but women get a longevity benefit too uh
people who are more socially connected
live longer people who are more socially
connected and not lonely have slower
cognitive decline as they get old they
are uh less likely to develop dementia
if they're more socially engaged
and they develop it later if they're
going to develop it
so all of these things are backed by
hard scientific data
it's I I had a conversation about a year
and a half ago talking about divorce and
it was the same Insight that you had
that loneliness is the same impact of
smoking half a pack of cigarettes every
single day and it just
it's such a non-galve at the moment I
don't think that this uh view of
relationships as being an impact on our
health has really hit people
sufficiently hard it doesn't Galvanize
your motivation in the same way as
stopping smoking or stopping eating
rubbish food or you know reducing your
alcohol content on the night time and I
do think that this is just conceptual
inertia that it as yet hasn't been
impacted but one of the challenges is
that
stopping smoking changing your diet
improving your health regime all of
those are things that you are 100
completely in control of by its very
nature with relationships it takes two
to tango you need another person in the
situation and
I don't know how familiar you are with
this sort of vibe online this corner of
the internet but there is a a growing
cohort of people for whom they say I
don't need anybody in my life I've tried
to have friends or I've tried to have a
relationship and people are just too
difficult I'm alone wolf I don't need
anybody and they're as convinced as it's
possible to be about this stance and
they're killing themselves and I I
really want
I really hope that this conversation
sort of drives it home that
you can
eat all of the organic food that you
want you can train as much as you want
you can do all the rest of it but if
you're neglecting your social
relationships you're literally killing
yourself
that's true however that's on average it
might be that if you just find people
toxic maybe the less stressful thing for
you is to remain alone who knows like
it's all you know we're talking about
big statistical averages right and you
know uh individual performance may vary
as they say in the prospectuses
everyone's super idiosyncratic everybody
is an N of one yeah I understand exactly
exactly
um but it is it is really important to
call out this idea that well I've this
is never going to happen for me there
are people who in fact people in their
20s have said to me it's too late for me
like it's like really
um but what we find you know when we
follow all these lives for decades is
that it's never too late that it people
get surprised by what happens to them
that we've had people in their 50s 60s
80s find a group of friends like they've
never had before or if find love people
find love in their 70s and 80s who they
who've never had it before
so what I want to just name is that if
you think it's never going to happen for
you you don't know you just don't know
what's gonna happen
I have a friend who is in his late 60s
and he recently had a child with his
partner and he was talking to me just
before Christmas and said I I didn't
really understand what it meant to have
a family in the same kind of way now and
there's dogs and there's wife and
there's baby and there's him and this is
a guy who's in his 60s learning what it
feels like to have a family unit and
it's it's beautiful it's really really
it's insane it's so beautiful yeah what
you were talking about before is that
what you refer to as Social Fitness is
that what you mean by Social Fitness
well Social Fitness is this idea like
physical fitness that it's a practice
that it's that it's not something to
take for granted when I was in my 20s I
used to think well my friends are my
friends they're always going to be my
friends I don't have to do anything but
what we see as people go through their
lives is that perfectly good
relationships can wither away just from
neglect and so
we coined this term Social Fitness to be
analogous with physical fitness you know
if you work out today you don't come
back home and say good I'm done I never
have to do that again we know that it's
an ongoing practice and what we find is
that the people who are best at
maintaining vibrant connections they're
the people who work at it who and it's
small decisions it's not hard work it's
little things it's sending a text today
to somebody you haven't seen in a while
and say hey I'm thinking about you just
wanted to say hi
um you know it's that kind of thing
there is a uh quote that I put in my
newsletter a couple of months ago if you
don't grow together you grow apart
and I think that that it's very
difficult to reach inertia with a a
friendship it usually turns and I I can
see this in my own life my friendships
are either getting better or getting
worse very few of them stay the same and
even if it is staying the same that's
effortful not staying staying the same
just idling away on neutral in cruise
control it's effort in order to keep it
at that same level it's not nothing
right I came back
I came back to the UK I think
four times last year
once was for a bachelor party once was
for the wedding that the bachelor party
was for yeah and then the final time was
for Christmas and I'd be there at the
beginning of the year like those things
like yeah I probably didn't need to come
back for the bachelor party that was
that was elective but I know that apart
from the fact it was great and I care
about him coming back has kept a ton of
friendships it's taking over it was an
important investment that I needed to
make exactly showing up really matters
and that's what actually one of my
teachers once told me when he said when
in doubt show up for people like just
just do it right you know and that
that's for weddings for funerals for
whatever it forever it is if you think
about going if you think about picking
up the phone do it you know act on the
impulse don't second guess it unless
it's three in the morning and you don't
want to wake up your friend but uh
really make yourself overcome those
those doubts how can people understand
the influence of their childhood on
their adult relation ships
we know that childhood matters a lot
because you know we're raised in these
families that teach us what to expect of
the world they teach us what to expect
of other people you don't as a
three-year-old think well I wonder what
other fathers are like or other mothers
this is just like this is what moms are
like this is what dads are like this is
it right and so it's very powerful and
it's only as we get older and we we our
world broadens that we begin to look
around and say oh families can operate
differently and by then we've really
been conditioned to have certain
expectations of our relationships and of
the world
and those expectations don't have to be
our destiny so like if you've had bad
relationships with parents with siblings
if you've come to believe they can't be
trusted
that can change but it means cultivating
and finding relationships with people
who are more trustworthy who are not
hurtful
so it can change we saw it change in
many of the people we studied
but in some of the people we studied
they ended up recreating the same kinds
of relationships they had in childhood
and so it really is a matter of trying
to find relationships that don't
make you relive your childhood if your
childhood was hurtful if we're lucky and
we had good childhoods then we want to
find relationships that are similar to
what we had in childhood isn't it
strange that we um we sort of look for
Comfort even in a a pretty nasty place
to grow up in later life yeah that's one
of the I learned that from Orlando
button from the school of life it's one
of the oddest and kind of most
uncomfortable sides of our preferences
for partners is that a lot of the time
we look for some of the negative
qualities that we had in our parents you
know to me it's not surprising because
one of the things we gravitate toward is
what feels like home
what feels familiar even if it's not
good even if it's painful and so like
because you know oh I know what this
feels like and oh this feels so familiar
and so what we find and Freud talked
about this and I see this all the time
so I do my specialty in in Psychiatry is
doing Psychotherapy so I see people
every day in Psychotherapy and one of
the things I notice is that they end up
seeking out they're like heat-seeking
missiles they seek out what feels
familiar and sometimes that's painful
stuff that feels familiar and so part of
the learning in a good Psychotherapy is
to help people see oh my God I'm
choosing I'm choosing the wrong partners
because they feel so much like the
people I knew as a kid
what else had important impacts on
happiness health relationships have you
got any idea what comes next
luck there is a lot of luck
you know uh some when our health breaks
down it's harder to maintain
relationships we don't have the energy
we don't feel as well so there's a lot
of luck
um and I and I want to name that because
uh
there it really it really does matter
what happens to us and we can't control
everything that happens to us I'm
stating the obvious but sometimes people
can believe that it's their fault if bad
stuff happens and so much of the time
it's nobody's fault
um and so I just I just want to name
that so that we don't end up leaving
people feeling blamed if they're not
having the life they'd hoped for
what about achievement does achievement
have a an input on happiness
it does and it doesn't like so
achievement does like if you do things
you're proud of so like I'll give you an
example like we've written this book and
I love this book like I feel good you
know because it conveys ideas that
matter to me personally very deeply
right so I want to get this book out
there
um and that achievement feels good to me
but
does it feel good if it's named to this
or that or when's this or that award
yeah it'll feel good maybe for a day but
that's it you know like we know Nobel
Prize winners who get depressed after
they win the Nobel Prize because it's
like well but now I still have to live
my life and it's just my life right gold
medalist syndrome yeah exactly exactly
so really it's that achieving something
that's meaningful to you can feel good
because you care about it right and
that's good so you know your personal
best in something like I ran that race
at my personal best and that feels good
to me uh that's a good thing so so in
that way achievement can matter in a
good way but achievement as a way to be
a badge of having arrived
that never lasts what about income did
you look at that I mean I've heard a
number of uh insights around where that
relates to happiness yeah well you know
there's this famous study that I know
you've heard of about five thousand
dollars seventy five thousand dollars a
year and that amount varies but but
basically
what all the studies show us is that we
do need to have our basic needs met
economically to have a sense of
well-being and so that means having
enough money for food and shelter and
health care and education to take care
of our families okay but once we get
there then adding income doesn't doesn't
increase our happiness and that's what
people find it hard to believe wait you
mean that making 75 million dollars
isn't going to increase my happiness
actually no it won't decrease your
happiness either but it won't make you
happy and it's a cliche that money
doesn't buy happiness but it's a cliche
for a reason because people end up
finding figuring it out right they did
this study of lottery winners you know
people who win scads of money through
luck right and they find that their
state of well-being goes back to a
baseline a year before they won the
lottery it goes back to about that a
year after they win the lottery same
thing it happens to people that become
disabled as well exactly exactly
adaptation is a hell of a drug so um
when you I will send it over on email
afterward that book don't trust your gut
by Seth
um he tries to dig into this as well I
think it'd be interesting for you guys
to look at too what he seems to find is
that there is definitely a top-out it's
around about that sort of figure that
sort of upper like tens of thousands
um and then in order to achieve the same
increase in happiness you need to double
the amount of money that you earn so in
order to be able to get the increase in
happiness that you would from uh let's
say 75 70 to 140 you then need to go 140
to 280 and then 280 to 560. so it's this
ever decreasing tolerance or ever
increasing tolerance should I say yeah
for money
um yeah right what he's pointing to is
you know what the economists call
diminishing returns that you can work
harder and harder make more and more
money and you get less happiness as a
result
what about
at a population-wide Trends because
there is a but criticism at the moment
that we are becoming ever more detached
from the typical kind of life that we
would have lived men's testosterone
levels have dropped by one percent every
year since 1980 you know we have chronic
diseases loneliness all of this sort of
stuff
have you guys been able to work out
whether self-rated happiness in 1940 was
higher than self-rated happiness in
2020. we have not been able to work out
that uh I I don't know if anybody has
studied it the difficulty is using
measures that are essentially either the
same or equivalent and and and so we
have that all the time you know we ask
we ask the same questions about marriage
uh eight times over five decades right
and just happened that we repeated those
questions but that's rare still I think
your question is super interesting and I
don't know that anybody has done that
comparison I think the other question I
would add to it is
were there different priorities so did
you know this kind of sense of Happiness
as in hedonic well-being I bet that
wasn't so much a thing I people talk to
more in our study the World War II
generation talked more about
um having a meaningful life taking care
of families that kind of thing rather
than uh actualizing my true self that's
become more of a kind of 1980s on
concept yep so I had a theory about that
as well that I've been playing with for
ages which is mazzo's hierarchy of needs
which he didn't actually make as a
pyramid to begin with but Mazda's
hierarchy of needs well you've got your
food and shelter etc etc all the way up
Social connection
if you are somebody for whom the bottom
level of that pyramid is not yet filled
worrying about whether you're
actualizing your logos and speaking your
truth forward into the world is not a
luxury that you can have an existential
crisis is not oddly a very luxurious
position to be in because it's only been
enabled due to the fact that all of the
bottom levels of the pyramid have been
fixed exactly exactly the other critique
of Maslow which I share is that it's
very inter individually focused very
self-focused I want to put my truth out
into the world I want to express my true
self as opposed to
investing in things beyond the self in
taking care of others and seeing oneself
as part of a much larger whole you know
which Maslow's hierarchy doesn't do
given that you are somebody who has a
background clinically and in terms of
practice and now in terms of data and
research what are the daily practices
that you do yourself to
um give yourself the best chance to be
happy in life
yeah they're kind of simple and dull I
meditate every day I exercise every day
I connect with people every day those
are the three things
and sometimes I watch Trash TV
that can also be a contributor to yes I
suppose yeah well and and I eat dark
chocolate Okay dark chocolate is the key
to happiness we can I think so I take it
from there all right um what's next for
this study that you guys are doing is
there anything else that you're thinking
that you would love to to work on with
the the cohort well we're collecting
data even now as we speak on the second
generation cohort and what we've focused
on this time so we come back in
different waves this time we're focusing
on what was life like for you during the
pandemic what's it been like and tell us
more about your use of social media
because we're interested in and these
are all mostly Baby Boomers so it's a
particular cohort their social media use
is different from you know
12 year olds and 25 year olds
but
we're interested in that
um and I think we're interested in
collaborating with other researchers a
lot we've always done that
we're doing it more so right now we're
collaborating with another research
study looking at
exposure to lead in the environment
because we know where people grew up and
we know whether they're
houses were in buildings that had lead
piping in the buildings we know how how
near they live to what are called lead
smelters that used to put tons of lead
into the air as they melted scrap lead
down and what so how much did lead
exposure
influence their health their well-being
how did it influence how long they lived
so we're collaborating with another
study that followed people from the time
they were young until they died and
we're pooling our data and we're going
to find out does it do this exposure to
toxins really matter and in what ways
because it still is a thing you know we
still have lead in our water in our air
um and so we're trying to be if we can a
little more socially active in
understanding the the conditions that we
need to create to Foster well-being
that's very cool Robert Walden ladies
and gentlemen if people want to check
out the stuff that you do where should
they go
uh so we have a book website it's
thegoodlifebook.com
um but in addition you could go to our
study website the website is adult
development study all one word adult
development
study.org and you'll get lots of
technical papers if you do Robert I
appreciate you I love your work thank
you thank you this is such an
interesting interview I really
appreciate it what's happening people
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace
[Music]